A football match is played with two teams of eleven players,...
...a referee, and two assistant referees on the touchlines.
It comprises two halves, 45 minutes each.
The ball's circumference is 68 to 70 centimeters and it weighs 410 to 450 grams.
Euro 2016, the usual UEFA disciplinary rules apply.
A player who receives a red card is sent off and receives an automatic ban for the next match.
The same applies if a player receives two yellow cards during a single game,...
...considered the equivalent to a red card,...
...the player is immediately excluded for the rest of the match.
During Euro 2016, if a player receives a yellow card in two consecutive games,...
...he isn't sent off during play but is banned from taking part in the next match.
Many tournaments like the European Championships cancel out single yellow cards...
...after the quarterfinal stage.
If multiple teams have the same number of points, additional criteria are taken into account...
...including goal difference and even team behavior in terms of fair play.